à aux clayes-sous-bois pardon ils seront
cinq candidats parmi eux nicolas eu un
bon soir vous êtes élue d'opposition
depuis 15 ans dans la commune pour la
première fois vous êtes candidat tête de
liste pour ce scrutin des municipales
votre liste un autre projet pour les
clayes-sous-bois une candidature qui est
soutenu notamment par plusieurs partis
de gauche génération auquel vous
appartenez mais aussi l a france
insoumise le ps le parti communiste ou
encore europe ecologie les verts
comment se déroule votre campagne est ce
que de nouveaux rendez vous sont prévus
dans les dernières semaines qui
précèdent le scrutin tout à fait alors
cette campagne se passe très très bien
comme nous l'avons commencé nous la
poursuivons c'est à dire que nous allons
à la rencontre des clés siens en
diverses temps des porte à porte des
réunions publiques comme nous avons
précisément commencé cette campagne en
créant justement le projet avec eux nous
continuons et nous continuons à élaborer
avec eux et donc nous avons des réunions
publiques qui sont prévues cette semaine
le 3 mars et le 5 mars une dans chaque
quartier de la ville
et puis la dernière le 9 mars quelques
jours avant le premier tour
pour ces derniers jours avant le premier
tour des municipales alors samedi
dernier vous avez organisé une opération
à la recherche et des pistes cyclables
oakley ça ça fait partie des
propositions phares vos portes et
développer un réseau cyclable aux
clayes-sous-bois tout à fait d'un point
de vue général évidemment la question
écologique et environnementale est un de
nos points et un de nos axes principal
est un de nos points forts et nous avons
justement essayer de diagnostiquer sur
l'ensemble de la commune
l'ensemble des réseaux cyclables qui
serait à mettre en oeuvre et à
développer des réseaux partagés ou des
roseaux en propre et notamment en lien
avec nos communes voisines villepreux et
plaisir puisque nous sommes réellement
un briquet ces trois communes les unes
dans les autres et nous paraissaient
importantes de diagnostic diagnostiqué
par nos la manière de relier ces trois
villes pour nous rendre vers les centres
commerciaux ou les sites administratifs
de ces trois villes
parce que ce genre de projet il faut le
penser à un niveau intercommunal
le définir avec les autres communes ça
ça déjà il faut manier évidemment
correctement la ville c'est à dire que
les trois quartiers que comporte notre
ville quartiers nord quartier ouest et
quartier centre soit correctement reliés
les uns aux autres et puis il me semble
bien entendu que lorsque nous avons des
communes hocine metref que plaisir et
villepreux
il faut penser évidemment à pouvoir
mailler ses réseaux avec ces communes
pour que les habitants d'une commune
puisse se développer de manière puis
cependant se déplacer d'une manière
tranquille d'une voix et d'une commune à
l'autre et ce de manière sécurisée
mais vous l'avez dire ça fait partie
bien sûr de vos propositions en matière
de transition écologique et on peut le
dire l'un des thèmes phares de cette
campagne des municipales
que peut faire le maire justement sur
cette thématique de la transition
écologique sur la transition écologique
il ya beaucoup de choses à mettre en
oeuvre et notamment par exemple une d un
des points qui nous nous tient à coeur
sur sur les clayes-sous-bois c'est la
maîtrise de notre urbanisme et la
maîtrise mais le respect de notre
environnement et de nos espaces verts je
prends pour exemple le centre et le parc
des bruyères qui est aujourd'hui un gros
sujet au sein de la ville que la
majorité sortante aujourd'hui divisée en
deux listes
madame frémaux et mais ceux qui viennent
souhaite bâtir de nouveaux pour du
logement et du logement d'un certain
niveau nous nous souhaitons que ces sept
mille mètres carrés en plein coeur de
ville de l'espace de verdoyant et des
espaces de verdure puisse rester ainsi
parce que c'est justement un projet qui
est totalement anachronique
on se rend compte que dans de nombreuses
communes aujourd'hui on fait le choix
inverse de revégétaliser nos espaces or
là on nous demanderait de re bétonner un
espace qui aujourd'hui déjà un verdoyant
c'est totalement contre contre nature et
contreproductif et nous nous souhaitons
évidemment préserver ce centre est ce
parc en y installant un projet
intergénérationnel qui allie les
personnes âgées et évidemment les plus
jeunes d'entre nous autre point qui est
ressorti de votre co construction du
programme avec les siens c'est le thème
de la sécurité qui est un thème qui
intéresse en tout cas qui peut être
inquiète aussi les clés siens tout à
fait
aujourd'hui les listes la majorité
sortante essentiellement focalisé son
attention sur la question de la
vidéosurveillance c'est c'est une chose
qui s'est développé je pense que nous
avons maintenant sur la ville un réseau
assez mallet de caméras de
vidéosurveillance mais pour moi rien ne
remplace la présence humaine et c'est
pour ça que nous allons nous proposer
que nous proposons à renforcer justement
les équipes de médiation sociale
nous partons nous sur un triptyque qui
est simple c'est prévenir agir et
sanctionner prévenir et agir c'est
évidemment avec une équipe de médiateur
social une équipe de correspondants nuit
puisque nous savons aussi que de
nombreuses incivilités se produisent à
partir de 20h 21h jusqu'à une heure du
matin et qu'il faut qu'il y ait un lien
là entre les habitants et les services
de police qui peut être justement prise
en charge par la puissance publique à
travers les correspondants de nuit et le
troisième axe sur l'instruction ou
blesse sur l'action est évidemment pour
nous le renforcement des forces de
police sur le secteur notamment avec la
création d'une police de sécurité du
quotidien qui est d'ailleurs un projet
qui a été proposé par le ministère de
l'intérieur il ya déjà deux ans et nous
souhaitons nous nous y inclure parce que
il nous paraît important d'avoir les
trois maillons de cette chaîne
mis bout à bout pour que enfin on puisse
vivre de manière à ses curés en tout cas
sereine aux clayes-sous-bois un dernier
mot très rapide sur un autre thème la
démocratie participative aussi qui
revient souvent dans cette campagne des
municipales
est ce que si vous êtes élu maire vous
allez aller vers davantage de démocratie
participative est ce que c'est votre
souhait donc les sous-bois oui je pense
que c'est nécessaire
en 19 ans les clients n'ont jamais été
réellement consulter
sur les grands projets d'envergure de la
commune je parlais tout à l'heure du
centre de loisirs des bruyères je parle
maintenant je peux parler aussi
maintenant du marché de la
restructuration du marché
nous voyons aujourd'hui la
restructuration du pôle gare dans lequel
les chrétiens avaient des demandes et il
avait proposé dé de nombreuses choses
qui n'ont pas été prises en compte par
la maire sortante et pardon que son
équipe qui se représentent et nous nous
souhaitons aujourd'hui qu'il y ait une
vraie action de la part des chrétiens
une collaboration une co élaboration
avec nous de l'ensemble des dispositifs
que nous mettrons en place notamment à
travers les des dispositifs de votation
citoyenne qui permettront aux clés siens
de se prononcer sur des grands projets
d'envergure de la commune voilà pour vos
thématiques nicolas hulot merci d'être
passé en plateau je rappelle que vous
êtes la tête de liste d'un autre projet
pour les clayes-sous-bois je précise que
c'est votre première candidature en tant
que tête de liste aux clayes sous bois
et son candidat également dans la
commune
l adjointe anne claire vraiment le
premier adjoint philippe dit guen
olivier august 1 pour lutte ouvrière et
stéphanie jamin qui convient une
candidature citoyenne